in your book notes to screenwriters you
say that some writers are just wrong for
some screenplays how so the the truth is
that probably the number one reason why
we find problems in screenplays is that
it was the wrong writer for that story
for that project it's amazing how people
will sign up for something that they're
ill-equipped to do you know from a hole
for several different senses right so
the first sense of being the wrong
writer for the project is just that this
project is too technical for your skill
level so this happens a lot with
people's passions projects where they
have this dream movie that they've
wanted to write since they were seven
but they and then they they start to
learn screenwriting and they start on
that movie and no that should be like
your fifth movie or your maybe your
third movie but certainly not your first
one and so so there's just this the
first level is just you're not good
enough yet to take on a project of that
scope maybe it's too many characters
it's too complex and it's story the the
structure is just going to require more
from menu than you're able to give so
and then the second another part of that
is sometimes it's going to require a lot
of research from you that you're just
not able to commit to especially if
you're learning your craft people tend
to be focused on learning the craft and
not have time you know to go off to the
yukon to research you know how Eskimos
you know make well meat or something you
know I think that that kind of weird
complexity that in a story of terms of
research is the wrong project to start
with so a research previ project
shouldn't be your first project a very
technical project with a lot of
characters and ensemble piece shouldn't
be your first project so from a from one
level that that you know you have to
measure the projects you take on
according to the skill set you have and
as it grows the projects can be more
complex and just think of it like any
other skill based craft if you're an
architect you don't build your
skyscraper first you know you start with
a dog house you build a garage and then
you work your way up so one of the
reasons the writers we see writers set
themselves up to fail
technically because they're just they
haven't really assess the needs of the
project and their own craft level and
another way that writers tend to fail in
this area is they're taking on projects
that weren't truly theirs to take on and
any story is is organically just
ingrained in the heart and the mind and
the soul of the writer and a writer
really needs to know himself and know
what kinds of stories he's uniquely
designed to tell and and stick with
those things and sometimes especially
when it's a job it's you know the
temptation is there to jump on that idea
and say yes I want to do that you know
I'm you know I don't know anything about
Eskimos but I can learn by gum and but
if if that's a story that where they
have no context and know not only just
personal experience but something that
really doesn't speak to their heart or
their mind or their soul then they're
not the right person for that story and
and the best stories come from writers
who can combine their own passions their
own interests their stories that really
speak to them and who they are as human
beings and they're able to tie in those
themes that they're grappling with and
wrestling with as people as human beings
and then apply that to the story or to
the project and and that's a great segue
to the third wrong reason that reason
that a script would be wrong for
somebody and it has to do with emotional
maturity so you know if your theme is
going to be you know something very
gritty and intense emotionally or
psychologically you got to be ready to
go there and travel into that dark place
perhaps and and be you know you know
live in it and a lot of writers just
aren't I had an experience once with a
project where it was about a
mother-daughter thing and I think we
tell the story in the book where the
producer said to the writer you're just
not going there in this scenes between
the mother and daughter the tension and
it turned out the writer had real
mother-daughter issues and she was
afraid
go into that place so they kept trying
to get her to go there and she just
wouldn't because she's afraid what her
mother would think you know but she's
also afraid to - she needed therapy
before she can write that out you know
and conversely some writers are so there
that they can't turn it into a story and
and that's the other side of the coin is
that sometimes writers need to pull back
from personal experience and I you know
when we when we consult with writers a
lot of them say well this really
happened to me we want to and we're like
no we need to tell a story with a
beginning middle and end here you know
and many of our own personal stories
don't resolve that same way how are you
able to tell that maybe the writers too
close to the material that's interesting
well one way is when they say this was
this happened to me you know yes you
know then right then it's a red flag
yeah you try to give them notes and say
you know this this character is
unbelievable and they will say well
that's what I did really happen yeah
you're not a character you're a person
you know when characters are not people
they're they're better than people you
know so I think that that's one sign
that they can be extremely touchy about
the material very you know they're not
able to just put it on the table and you
have the sense when you're giving them
feedback this is about them and their
problem with their friend or their
husband or their mother and you're
suddenly in a therapy session instead of
a note session you know and and they
people can get very defensive it's just
clear you know what you're not distant
enough from this material to be writing
about this but it's it's amazing how
many people want to write the story of
the terrible thing that happened to them
and in almost in kind of a way to
process it you know but this isn't about
entertainment you know it's like get
some therapy that's that might be a good
place to draw most people need a few
years between what happened and writing
about what happened in order to really
process it into something that's going
to work for more than one person what
our notes and how should a writer
approach getting feedback well most
writers are pretty nervous when they are
receiving feedback and it
be a very stressful thing for a writer
to walk into a potentially unknown
situation usually the people that you're
getting notes from are people that
you've either first met you don't have a
relationship with just yet at least in
the professional setting or perhaps
you're in a writers group and if it's a
competitive environment that can also be
a very stressful place sometimes and one
of the first things that we do when we
work with our clients is we just talk to
them we help them to calm down we help
them to get comfortable because in order
to to receive notes in order to give
notes there needs to be a level of trust
and understanding that the people in the
room are truly trying to help the
project and it's it's even though the
process of writing really requires
writers to put their whole heart and
soul into something this is not the time
or place to put your whole heart and
soul on the table it's time to step back
and be objective and really think about
what the project needs not what the
writer needs that can be a hard thing I
think that one of the big messages of
our book is to the kind of subtext
message to writers is don't set yourself
up for failure and one of the ways that
writers set themselves up for failure is
they ask the wrong people to give them
feedback on their work and we see this
all the time so wrong people to give
feedback would be people who who really
they they're your cheerleader you know
now at a certain point you do you
absolutely do need cheerleaders in this
field it's a very demanding field and
you need people who just believe in you
and tell you you know you're gonna get
through this and you're gonna be great
and I can't wait to see your movies etc
but you don't give your mother your
screenplay and say you know what do you
think is it any good because chances are
unless she's Mommy Dearest you know
she's gonna say this is great you know
and and and then people who know you too
well they they read between the lines
you know and it may not be on the page
what they're reading so one of the
things is you know a writer absolutely
needs feedback at a certain point
because you you you plateau in your
skills and and
the idea of putting your work in front
of people who can really help you take
it to the next level take yourself to
the next level as a writer and maturing
your skills realize wow this is you know
I'm kind of on the verge here but I'm
just not getting into excellence in this
skill at people who know the artform who
really have the ability to to not only
see what's wrong with something but then
even analyze and say why it's wrong one
of the things that we find in this
industry is sadly and it's one of the
reasons stuff gets worse as it goes
through the development process is that
the people giving notes very have very
little command of the art form itself
and that's something that a writer needs
to expect you know I've worked for a
whole slew of producers who didn't know
what I was talking about when I said
inciting incident or the first turning
point or the arc of transformation you
know any of the kind of standard jargon
that storytellers write screenwriters
use and I've had producers just look at
me blank faced and say basically you
know just make it so that everybody
wants to see it and we make 10 million
dollars you know they bet yeah like they
don't care and the truth is is that many
projects are greenlit because somebody
likes penguins or somebody likes
princesses and it's all you know a lot
of it is based on personal taste but
that's not going to give you a great
story
and producers don't always have the
story skills to be able to separate what
their personal taste is from what a good
story is and that so that really falls
on on the writer trying to interpret
what these notes are and hopefully they
have a strong they have strong people
around them to help them navigate that
process but it's really has to be a very
kind of like a an adventurer a seeker in
the notes process they can't take
anything at face value so I had a
producer say to me not long ago we're
getting feedback that your script is a C
script and I've read a lot of scripts my
script isn't a C script I knew it's not
discrete it's not perfect but I knew it
was in a C script so then I start saying
well well what do you mean and
you know we kind of went to this whole
thing where it turned out basically only
three people had look at it looked at it
two of them were people that weren't
really had done anything didn't know
what they were talking about and one was
somebody who want his favorite movie is
kung fu you know something it was like
nothing like this movie anyway so what I
found out was that the people that were
giving him notes were the wrong people
to really be assessing this and and and
he really didn't care he just wants to
sell the movie so I think that that
writers one of the things we're trying
to do in notes to screenwriters is help
writers hear a note and then not take it
at face value try to get underneath the
note to you know what isn't happening in
the reader that should be that this note
is kind of signifying so not to dismiss
the notes but also not to take them at
face value and and then you know when
you're when you're actually when you're
at the stage of just trying to get your
script ready the feedback that you get
really needs to be tailored to your
growing and the project growing so
you've got to be careful that the people
you give your script to are people who
know what they're talking about you know
that some some medieval Saint said once
a bad spiritual director is worse than
none at all and it's just true in
screenwriting too bad
notes are worse than none at all and
they can really send you spinning but if
you are working with people who don't
have a lot of experience giving notes
some of the best notes that somebody
like that can give is something along
the lines of well this is where I
dropped out or this is where I lost
interest or this is where I didn't
understand notes like that can be really
helpful for a trained writer because
they can then go back and look at those
areas and fix them based on that kind of
response the number one thing to get
past your terror of notes is to get a
lot of it and we recommend every writer
this serious should be in a writing
group they should be in this process
where they're getting feedback regularly
so it so it's not the scary thing you
know after you've had your scripts read
you know for three or four years in a
writing group you just you get you're
able to separate yourself from it and
and so writers absolutely need feedback
to grow they got to get used to
you back and so they just got to be and
put themself in an environment where
they're getting good stuff so being in a
good writer group with other
screenwriters who know the art form who
are also you know working on their
skills this is a we think it's essential
for the writer and with that mentoring
mentoring is extremely important for
somebody starting out to start to train
their own ear in what kind of feedback
is necessary and proper at different
stages of the script speaking of what
we're talking about taking a darker turn
how does a writer know they're getting
notes from let's say Saboteur in some
sense and maybe it's not that they're
trying to really hold them down maybe
they're afraid they don't want them to
succeed or whatever it is you know you
have a cheerleader your family maybe
your friends but there are also people
that won't be truthful and the notes are
giving you and it's a darker angle
that's a great question because there's
a lot of competition and a lot of
jealousy sometimes among writers
particularly in writers groups and and
it is important to weed out the people
who could be potentially sabotaging a
project but I would say you know if
you're getting notes that sound like
they are first of all attacking the
writer those should be thrown out well
you know across the board those are not
helpful in any way and then if it's a
note that attacks the that attacks the
project but is given in a way that is
trying to destroy rather than build up
that's not going to be helpful either
and just in general you know even a hard
note a heart a note that is hard to hear
there is some element of hope in that
note for the sake of getting better and
growing and so you know if you take the
metaphor of pruning a lot of notes are
about pruning things back and clearing
things away but that's only for the new
good things to grow stronger and better
yeah I've we've both received just awful
notes and I and in terms of somebody
using the notes process in a destructive
way one time I had a producer who we had
we had tension on a project and she
wanted to take me down a peg and
I I kind of felt that and she you know
she said as much but so then on a script
she said what's this this line in the
script here what is that and I said well
that's you know it's a joke it leads
into the scene and she said a joke a
joke well it's not funny and you're not
funny you know so just take everything
out of the script that you think's funny
because that'll save me time all right
now this is a great example of somebody
who's now moved beyond the notes process
into trying to rein in the writer or
rein and you know whatever by you know
really just kicking somebody in the gut
and when you get when you hear something
like that you know and you can just kind
of tell you know this is went right to
the personal just dismiss it there's
nothing there for you to hear and we can
only say that in the strongest terms
because it can be debilitating to a
writer that kind of personal attack and
you need to be away from that person if
you can I mean if they if they're if
they're your boss and the project
producer you're kind of stuck with him
and you just got to find a way to cope
but thank goodness every project is
temporary but for us that would be that
person if somebody did that in a writing
group they're out yeah you know that's
how serious it is you need to just sever
your connection with somebody who goes
after you like that because it's just as
too hard as it is to do this stuff
without somebody really turning you know
your efforts at becoming a professional
into personal attack and you just you
got to fortify yourself so constructive
criticism with a ray of hope that that's
how you would know that it's actually
useful and not try someone really trying
to wound someone yeah you know I mean
sometimes it becomes obvious that the
writer has an issue when we're working
with them like the mother issue you know
kind of thing but we don't go there
really unless we're invited to and
that's another thing you know when it
moves into the personal the writer it
really needs to be the one to say to you
you know I wonder if I have mother
issues and I can't do this story and for
him for us to make that jump it's very
unprofessional you know where they're
talking about when we read this scene
this is where it leaves us it's not
bringing us where it needs to and that's
pretty much the best kind of feedback
for a writer to get so so yeah any kind
of personal stuff it now you've moved
out of the realm of professionalism and
and we're very big on this is a
profession and a craft and you need to
have
standards of behavior that's one of the
whole third part of notes to
screenwriters is about that and because
we've seen too many people fail because
they you know they it this is
storytelling
it's about the deepest human things in
you and it's very easy to let that human
stuff kind of you know spill into the
profession of the professional side but
you've got to keep them separate yeah we
talk about the various phases of giving
notes like what would be the first step
well notes first of all are you know not
just what you're getting from producers
we're getting from potential investors
or you know directors when we see notes
when Hollywood says notes it's anybody
giving you some point on something
you've written that would make it better
that would go to make it better so
writing group gives you notes your
writing partner gives you notes your
anybody you've handed your script to
will give you notes that's the word that
Hollywood uses and it's kind of funny
you know it's like a joke in the
industry when anybody will say anything
and then some of those a I have notes
you know in other words you know I got
could tweet that and make it just better
whatever it is right now so mentors
producers finance people sometimes give
notes directors the thing that changes
then is there that we have there's kinds
of notes and then there's the you know
who's giving the notes and how much
attention you have to give to them so so
you know the kinds of notes say we have
something we call line notes then you
have broad story notes you have
character notes you have you know all
things that have to do with the content
and you know there might be that you get
some notes on you as the the writer you
know you're not going there you're not
doing your research and other things
like that but but you know that the the
idea of knowing in every context okay
what kind of notes am I going to be
getting what should I be expecting here
so that you go into a note session and
say this is what I'm looking for and
this is what they should be providing me
and again in terms of setting yourself
up for failure one of the things that
happens is that there's not that joint
expectations so the producer has one
thing that they're thinking to talk
about and the writers going in you know
with their little notebook open to get
another thing and that G things never
they're trying to get notes that may be
a mentor would give as opposed to a
producer and that can be a problem
sometimes yeah so so but the phases of
the notes yeah so um in almost every
note session it's really important to
start with the positive and start with
what's working about the project because
everything needs to be couched in that
and so many note sessions are focused on
the negative or on what's not working
that sometimes when you have when when a
script is 90% working and you're
focusing on that 10 that's not it's easy
to lose perspective as a writer so it's
really important if you're if you're
giving notes that you're really focusing
on okay these are the hundred things
that work and then now we're gonna focus
on the ten things that don't and then
also in every note session I think it's
extremely important to say right up
front what the purpose of the notes are
so whether you're talking about story
and character whether you're at a place
where it's appropriate to talk about
story and character or whether you're
talking about little nitty gritty
polished notes or typos those are very
different conversations and are
appropriate at different stages of
development and the writer has to
control this a little bit because a lot
of times the producers come into these
things and you know especially if
they're busy you know producers or you
know I'm saying producers or you know
somebody they they they just start
whipping things off you know and it's
like you know what you have a typo on
page ten and oh that that character just
I hate that could I never cared about
the character and you know I don't know
if this should be a comedy or a thriller
when you have a shooting script and
they're like well maybe it should be a
comedy instead of a drawing but you know
that that idea of throwing at the writer
like line notes you know like there's a
misspelling here I didn't think that
joke was funny and oh yeah that
character doesn't work okay this is a
note session that's out of control so
basically the writer should come in and
say okay this first write you know what
I'm looking for here in this
in this meeting is notes about the story
so so I know that there's typos or I
know that stuff later shouldn't be typos
but you know I I know that there's a
little stuff but let's just talk about
the story and here's here's the arc of
the first story a story what did you
think about that story did you did you
and to kind of really keep the note
giver on task giving you the feedback
that you need and when we when we mentor
writers we typically start with very
broad story notes so we're talking about
characters what they want and what they
need and what they're how they're going
to grow and change what their thrust is
going to be in the story and then we
talk about plot and and how that's
moving things along and we pretty much
stay there and theme a little bit but we
pretty much stay there when we're in the
beginning stages of story we don't go
into dialogue and we don't go into
format things like that because those
are our distractions to the meat and
potatoes of the story when you're at a
beginning stages of developing a project
now if you're to three drafts in it's
assumed that at that point you have your
story you have your characters and you
might still have one or two notes about
what some character does in particular
in a particular spot which may not be in
line with with you know the rest of the
story there might be something very
specific there but that's when you give
the notes that are you know very you
know nitpicky details and when you're
really getting into just the little
things if you're giving really big broad
story and character notes on a third
fourth draft there there's a big that
means that there's a really big problem
with the with the skeleton with the core
of that script and it probably needs to
be completely gutted and and retooled we
find that if you you take care of the
big issues it's amazing how many of the
little issues resolve themselves and yet
most writers are so resistant sometimes
to addressing the big issues because the
big issues
x is this plot just doesn't work you
know it just doesn't work and that one
is a note no writer wants to hear
because it means completely believed
yeah yeah we can see and so they do want
to focus on well did you like the little
subplot that takes place in the sardine
factory you know and it's like you know
we don't care about that right now we're
telling you that this characters overall
movement from you know A to Z to be is
not convincing and compelling and that's
what we need to go back to and they have
to get pulling the writer you know back
to that but again the writer needs to be
managing this notes process in a lot of
ways you know in everybody they meet
would they need to to know what they're
looking for and here's a red flag on
notes by the way to if someone who's
giving you notes tries to tell you how
to solve the problems in your story
chances are you should you should nod be
nice and get out because the truth is
the people are giving notes have read
your script once maybe twice they're not
invested they don't know what you've
rejected they don't know what you've
tried all they can do is tell you what
isn't working for them and that's the
feedback the writer needs as soon as the
note giver starts to say here's what you
need to do chances are they're
defaulting that that no cover is
defaulting to something they've seen in
a movie before or they've seen in a
story before and they're trying to plug
in a fix that day you know like kind of
some all-purpose fix you know you need
you need ten girls in a bikini in a car
to drive through you know executive
given note ones to a friend can't we get
a decapitation in before the midpoint
just to pick it up you know yeah but but
that that idea of trying to plug in a
fix you know or anybody trying to do
your job and it's like that's not the
note givers job the note givers job is
to say this is how this affected me this
is what I got out of this not this is
how you should fix it and the writer
really has to resist someone else
solving their problem trying to do their
job let's say a writer is moving up the
food chain with a project and they know
that they're going to have five minutes
and this person may go right for the
jugular and they've got to compose
themselves and they don't want to lose
this whole project what are some tips on
keeping calm
and really keeping your defenses back
because maybe whoever's going to deliver
these notes is a power player and
they're not going to be kind what are
some yeah well I mean what what's
implied there is that it's a high-stakes
situation and and now if this is
somebody who can literally greenlight
your movie you should definitely take
their note with you know but if they're
not if it's just somebody giving their
their two cents but they're a higher-up
if it's if it's a false sense of power
then you know they've got to take that
note just like they would with anybody
else I think the the you know the best
thing is to just tell yourself going in
this isn't me like this is my table that
this is this as a table there's my
script on the table and I'm over here
and what we're doing is talking about
that thing we're not talking about me as
much as you can separate yourself
emotionally from your work and I needed
the best way to do that write 10 scripts
write seven or eight spreads right
because the more are you doing or you do
the more it's just another project and
you know but if you've got this one and
this is your life and it's your passion
then then you're so invested in it but
you know there's nothing like being five
or six scripts past that one to make you
go back and say yeah I can lose that
that thing I'm so attached to you know
but I think that one of the signs of a
writer that's difficult is that they are
way too attached to the project it's way
too much about them which goes back to
it's too personal and personal right
yeah yeah you're not a professional in
terms of basic skills and natural gifts
how does one know they should be a
screenwriter it's a great great question
and amazing to us how few people ask
that question you know people decide
they want to be a screenwriter because
they like movies way too often or maybe
they don't even like movies but they
just had an idea that they thought could
be a movie a movie there there's so
there's not enough of people stepping
back and saying what are the essential
skills of this field and do I have them
and do I have them in like the top 10%
or even five percent you know and am I
willing to hang in there long enough to
develop yeah
I think that the number right now is 2%
of the members of the Writers Guild of
America make a living as screenwriters
so that means 98% are doing other things
too you know and so so but we think this
comes back to just um failure to really
stand back and say what natural
abilities should I have to be a good
screenwriter right so right off the top
we you have you got to have what we call
a honed story sense a honed story sense
this is somebody who has instincts about
story and we don't know where you get
this except from having read a lot of
stories you know so one of the things we
say all the time is great writers are
great readers you know so you you want
to get a you want to get good instincts
about a great character well you do this
by reading the Arabian Nights and the
Greek myths and the Brothers Grimm and
the Arthurian tales and and Count of
Monte Cristo and then as you move up you
know the read read the Russians read
read the great novels read Dickens and
and the Bronte's like you should be as a
storyteller somebody who is in the
company of storytellers has your
preferred place to be and you've
probably been devouring this your whole
life and this is something that is
developed
you know from kindergarten on is this a
sense of always wanting to be in story
and and I think that that's a natural
inclination that that speaks well to you
know a screenwriting career story is
like instinct you know either this is
this is a high-stakes choice this is a
real crucible situation some people have
that instinct and some people don't and
with they don't have it you know you're
sitting there trying to it's like trying
to explain to a duck why they should fly
south really hard okay no they they just
don't get it and and so we when we meet
somebody like that that has no instincts
in story we know I just want to tell
them you know in fact we give them a
list of the hundred most influential
stories ever written and I say go read
you know start knocking these off one a
month and in five years you'll be ready
and I would say the difference between
say a novelist and a screenwriter is a
scream in addition to all of these great
books screenwriters also watch a lot of
movies they
seen all the classics they are up on
what are you know what all the Academy
Award winners are for that year and they
they have a good sense of what's going
on in theirs onra that they're
interested in they're just constantly
taking in and and they're also reading
scripts it's really important for
screenwriters to read what's on the
written page in screenplay form because
that's going to say so much about it's
really just going to speak to everything
that they need to know technically about
how to tell a story and on the screen I
mean it's like an essential skill that
you got to have is a sense of the moment
that movies are combinations of beats
and moments right beats are something
happens in the plot somebody makes a
choice and it leads to this consequence
so that's part of the story sense you
know a choice something happening but
moments are the emotional stakes
underlying that choice so you know when
you think of a movie like Titanic you
know what's the moment ah those dudes
standing on the bow everybody can see
that moment right I'm the king of the
world right but that was a great great
moment that resonated with people so
having a sense of where are the moments
in my movie one of the complaints that
that we hear in the notes we hear from
people about movies today right and the
subtext complaint is I just sat through
a two hour movie where there were no
moments there was a lot of beats a lot
of stuff happened but I never felt an
emotional kind of plateau I'm you know
an emotional peak in this movie I never
felt like I wanted to laugh or I wanted
to cry or I felt outraged like I never
felt that so this idea of a writer
having kind of an a gut sense of what
makes a peak emotional moment you know
what what is that death cycle and it's a
psychological thing it's a psychological
dynamic so the writer needs to be a
psychologist and be able to say in my
story where the two or three key
emotional moments that I need to take
like the movie the pace needs to slow
down and we're gonna really go into it
and kind of saturate the audience in
this
and this experience emotionally really
have them crescendo in this kind of
weather whatever the if it's Patos if
it's you know sadness if it's anger if
it's fear whatever it is and so a lot of
times when I'll say to that writers you
know what are the key moments in your
movie and they'll be looking like you
know when the Stewart when the ship
sinks it's like no it's not when the
ship sinks it's when the ship sinks and
note that does to her you know the
character etc so so letting it land in a
sense it's not because I see a lot of
stuff today that it almost goes there
but it's move so fast keeps moving yeah
yeah and and I would say with
independent film you you also have the
reverse problem where if you have too
many moments it's not going anywhere
you're just sitting there watching
people in moat and and and then there's
no pace there's no dramatic tension and
that in that regard you just fizzles out
but yes you know I think that there's
you know both of them are are dangers
for sure and you know we have we have we
list actually seven in our book
essential skills for screenwriters I
think those are the two you know key
ones there but but you know the the main
thing is that to approach this field as
you know something that you have been
made to do because of your natural gifts
you don't just do it because you you're
like the glamour of the business or the
Hollywood thing you know all of that
stuff you know no you do it because you
were made to do this because the gifts
you have are geared towards this and so
one of the things we do in mentoring
writers at catharsis is to help them try
to figure that out you know do you have
the chops to do this professionally or
is it going to be a hobby for you
because there's raw talent there's
natural incan inclinations but then
there's also 10 years of hard work of
applying skills and building on skills
and really strengthening your muscles
and being able to be the right person to
tackle the project and that's a
long-term investment it's a marathon and
it really does take both in order to
have a career and
you know and I would say you can have
the skillset level also determines where
you're gonna play in this business right
so you know I have a sister she's a
professional opera singer and just like
you know the top 2% of opera singers
sing at the Met you know the top 10%
sing in San Francisco Denver you know
Chicago the top 20% sing in Portland you
know see ya you know Seattle whatever so
in other words it's possible to be a
dramatic writer of writing for the
screen but not necessarily playing at
the Hollywood studio level you can be
writing web series content that will get
an audience of a hundred thousands or
even the tens of thousands your skill
sets can take you there you can be in
the indie world where you're you know
you'll get in your lifetime
three checks for twenty thousand dollars
for different projects right but you can
make a little movie that will get seen
by you know tens of thousands of people
and few festivals I think that you don't
have to say if I can't play it at the
top level that I can't play at all so
one of the things we try to do in our
mentoring of the writers figure out
where your skill set is gonna put you
what percent where do you fall in you
know in terms of the most influence the
most impact the most money
how are you competing because again
don't set yourself up for failure if
you're only in the top 10% of writers
then don't try to play in a field where
the top 2% are going to be the ones who
have a let make a living out of it and
screen storytelling is so diversified
now that there's no reason to not find
your niche at this point so what does
that mean to say that a story is better
than the real we love that line story's
better than the real because one of the
things that we've figured out is a story
is a thing it's different than real life
and I mean you could you could talk
about that for ten years you know what
does that mean especially in the you
know in the realistic filmmaking you
know phase that you know we're seeing
especially the Indies but but the truth
is that a story isn't real life and in
in in some ways something's a story in
every way in which it's not real life
right so in real life
people are mainly mysterious to us they
we don't know why they do what they do
we don't have access to their
motivations story is not like that we do
have access to their motivations we do
know what's driving them so watching a
story you get a little surge of guilty
pleasure because it gives you something
real life cannot legitimately give you
that you have no right to want in real
life so if a movie is when we read a
script if it doesn't give that access if
it doesn't clarify the motives of the
character really what they want and what
they need and what's driving them it's a
bad story because that's one of the
things that people expect and story that
they're going for is access you know
emotional access and another way that
story is better than the real is that
the the settings are more interesting
than our everyday lives you know we
don't go to the movies to watch somebody
you know in the bathroom for an hour
getting ready for work you know that's
that's our everyday mundane life we go
to the movies to see beautiful
landscapes and beautiful vistas and to
see quirky worlds and quirky arenas that
are more interesting than our everyday
world and similarly we look the
characters in movies we like them
because there is something just a little
bit there they're like us but there's
just a little bit better than us and and
that's the that's the quality of a hero
is somebody who aspires to do the things
that we could grow up to do that are
within reach of what we could do but are
just you know they're just going a
little bit more beyond what we might be
doing in everyday life another way
stories are better than the real is that
they're structured around a theme
they're structured around some universal
truth about human life and this is not
your real life right your real life if I
say to you how did you learn you know
what's some big lesson you learned and
you say to me well I learned that it's
important to be truthful I learned this
you know by the time I was thirty that I
wasn't gonna lie anymore it's like okay
so that means you probably had a
thousand little incidents from the time
you were four
started talking where you started to
learn when I lie I get in trouble you
know and having to juggle story telling
and you know and all of this stuff and
so finally at the age of 30 you go going
I'm not gonna lie anymore right but it's
this cumulative thing that well in a
movie or in a story this happens in two
hours
there we where you take out all the
other lessons that people are learning
and you say we're just gonna look at how
Luke learned that he needs to trust the
force right you know in stars we're not
gonna look at all Luke's other problems
that that he's a slob or he has issues
with women or that he's you know he's
got jealousy stuff no we're just gonna
hone in on that so it's a very unnatural
structured around a themed experience so
when we read a screenplay that it just
seems to be all over the place we say
people this isn't gonna work
as a story because the audience doesn't
get what are we talking about here what
is this about and that's one of the big
notes that we end up getting all the
time that the writer hasn't been able to
really say this story is about this and
so I'm gonna eliminate everything that
isn't about that
you know the big idea that writers
sometimes just never made that choice
and so that you stand back from the
screenplay and you say I don't know what
this comes down to in the end I don't
know what this is really about so a
story is better than real life because
it gives us it really cuts out
everything that isn't on your main
universal truth and story also has a
resolution unlike real life where it
seems like we're always waiting for our
act 3 to happen we often don't know what
what resolutions are going to be
happening for us in our everyday world
but in a story it needs to resolve and
that that resolution needs to be
satisfying and it's the satisfaction
that comes from that resolution that
makes that story better than what we
normally go through in life and then on
top of that all the little elements of
story are better than real life so
dialogue you know in in to write a good
line of dialogue sometimes it'll take me
3 weeks and then 10 drafts later I'm
still tweaking that that come back think
about it as you have a fight with your
friend
and then you sit there in the shower
kind of replaying that and you keep
coming home I should say that like like
that's what movies are that the writer
has gotten that perfect response so you
have this perfect back-and-forth
repartee that real life never has if any
if people in real life talk the way they
do in the movies these will be crazy
people you know but in the movies it's
okay it's expected you know in
storytelling so the idea of everything
being honed to be entertaining to be
compelling to be a feast it's it's a
story is a feast as opposed to just
running through the frigerator open the
door and grab a few things that's real
life right but a story is a feast and so
that that as we say to our writers you
know your your your what you've done
here just isn't feasting enough it's
just not better enough than people's
real life and you know we always quote
this one line when the cinema verite
movement was going through the 50s
everybody was trying to do some realism
realism realism mainly coming out of
Europe cuz they don't have any money but
Hitchcock the Great Master said you know
some people want movies to be a slice of
life I want two movies to be a slice of
cake yeah and there it is you know that
movie is better than the real and that
it's a slice of cake and and if and if
it's we don't see it on the screen and
the the paper cuz you're trying too much
to be gritty and real then it's like why
would anybody want to do this and and
then the last thing I would say too is
that your movie needs to be at least as
good as the real but it needs to be
better than the real so in other words
it can't be such that people watch this
movie and go wow people don't talk like
that that would never happen this is so
boring it's like yeah alright you know
so those are signs if the script isn't
working that your movie as an even as
good as the real so you got a ten you
got to get to the real and then you got
to push it and be better than the real
how about the note that the characters
not relatable you know the idea that a
character is not Relater relatable or I
didn't care about the character is
that's probably the number one
note that we here thrown around
Hollywood and I would say that that's
also the number one note that new
writers are given when they're working
with material and we there there are a
lot of different things that can
contribute to this idea that a character
is likable or relatable and that's why
we have books like save the cat we're in
the title that's addressing that very
thing but at the same time they're what
we like to do is we like to go back to
what Aristotle teaches about what a
character is and we feel like that's so
many people right now are ignoring
classic storytelling and ignoring the
basics of character and if they only
would look at what has been taught over
the you know thousands of years about
character they could probably address
this this question yeah it's really not
rocket science for all of the the fact
that it is the thing that scuttles most
scripts Aristotle wrote 2,500 years ago
in the poetics that if you want the
audience to have an eventual cathartic
experience in your story that you need
to have that character be good be
appropriate be consistent and be
universal right so what does that mean
right that the the main character the
protagonist needs to be oriented towards
a good quest that the audience needs to
sign on and say yeah that's worth going
for there so you know look at the
Odyssey this famous Greek you know what
does he want he wants to get home he
wants to be with his wife the that's a
good question the audience goes yeah so
one way to scuttle your character right
away suppose their quest is I want to
make a million dollars I want to be the
richest stockbroker on Wall Street the
audience goes war right so we don't care
now right you know or you give them some
kind of a goal that that that just is
like weird or dark or hateful and and
now the audience goes yeah I I don't I
don't sign on to that and so now they
disconnect right you know they need to
be appropriate that is the main
character in a story needs to
have a substitutional roll for the
audience themselves they need to be
somebody that we feel safe with to say
that's gonna be me in the story I'm
gonna travel through that person's
experience in the story as though it was
mine that's why we laugh and cry and
feel scared what's happening on a flat
screen because we've actually moved into
that character's life if it's working so
if you make the character so off-putting
ly weird that the audience goes yeah I'm
not that guy
you know think about it the audience's
people are sheep if somebody comes in
and looks goofy and kind of strange
nobody's like you know everyone's like
give that guy some room all right so
this is tricky thing in a movie because
you need your character Beauty quirky
and better than the real they need to be
intriguing and interesting and a little
bit smarter or you know good at
something the audience isn't but they
can't be off-putting ly weird so the
audience feels we nervous about them now
you can absolutely have characters in
the movie who are that but not the
protagonist the main one through whom we
travel who's going to stand in for us
has to be somebody that we feel safe
with right appropriate yeah and an anti
hero's are really popular right now and
we generally recommend for beginner
writers to avoid the antihero genre
typically because it's they're just
requires so much skill to create a
character who is an antihero who is also
relatable who is also likable and you
know of course Walter White from
Breaking Bad is perhaps the best example
ever of an antihero who works but it's
because he has a very high-stakes
relatable background as a as a you know
he starts out as a real human being more
or less and then he turns into a monster
yeah and that that leads to the third
thing aerosol talks about consistency
that we can know why somebody is doing
what they're doing so their motivations
become huge and that we understand their
motivations so the way to disconnect
your character from your audience to
make them not care is if you never
really clarify what do they want what do
they want what are they trying to to do
what do they what are they why are they
doing what they're doing if I don't ever
understand why a character makes a
choice on the screen then yeah I
disengage
so that consistency becomes huge to make
me relate you know and then the last one
what what aerosol calls true that this
person struggling with a universal human
struggle that could be mine too
so one of the problems in a lot of
movies is the struggle is so
externalized to the particular world you
know it's like wow this is about a
nuclear scientist who's trying to blow
up an asteroid and it's like well why do
I care about that I will never do that
so what has to happen is it has to be
yes he needs to blow up the asteroid
because it's the way for him to show his
son that he isn't a failure and but I
think oh now it's my story right but but
see the writer who doesn't make that on
find that underlying universal story
that's common to all people now I never
care and and we see this again you know
the blockbuster era of Hollywood it's so
much about big things happening in weird
contrived places and yet if they don't
ever make that connection - how is this
a story that everyone and every time in
every place could sign on to let's talk
about what story is not alright well
there are many things that story is not
and it also relates back to this idea
that story is better than the real so
one of the things that story is not is
that it is not a literal day in the life
it is not just a you know plod through
the day and I said I get my coffee and I
wake up in the morning and I go to work
there's something that there there is a
core action or a core problem that is
bigger or better than the real that ties
it int that that can tie it into an
everyday situation but it's not just
those little everyday moments and I and
I just wanted to throw in there you know
boyhood was my favorite movie of the
year and I think that you know it breaks
all of these rules but the reason why it
works is that it's not just a day in the
life or recounting but
it's it's this also this device of
having happened over 12 years that makes
it so so fascinating and so there are
exceptions to this rule but on the whole
these are the things that that people
should avoid when they're approaching
their stories another one is random
musings you know this is you know it
seems to me where it's very pretentious
where you have some characters sitting
in a diner and somebody goes ketchup
what's that about right that and then
the movie just kind of moves through
people saying that you know it's funny
to point out that people think they're
profound when they're not once in a
while but if your whole movie is just
kind of like ketchup what's that about
you know the audience after about 20
minutes if that long will go what do I
need to be here for this what is this
and in it it feels very pretentious kind
of just fishing around well these are
just some people who really they had one
germ of an idea but they really didn't
think this through it doesn't have any
progression stories also it's not a
straight line it needs to go up and down
and around and there needs to be highs
and lows and I like it in the same way
that it's not a day-in-the-life
it's not well it's it's not just a
straightforward telling of events you
know another one is story is not a
fascinating place or even a really cool
event so we get pitches like this all
the time people like I'm gonna write a
story about or I have a movie about a
nuclear submarine and getting stuck on
the bottom of the ocean and we go what's
the story
it's the story and they're like uh
nuclear submarines on the bottom of the
ocean it's like that's not a story as
stories when you start telling me and
what the character stakes are you know
with that you know so another one is oh
wow I went to this amazing village in
China and you know that's at the village
where they make you know the Dragons for
the for the festivals it's amazing and
my my movie is like that village it's
like that's not a story that's an arena
so we're constantly having to help
writers distinguish a
really cool arena you know or an
interesting you know kind of event from
being a story those things aren't stolen
our or Chicago in the 20s you know again
great Goa great or you know but you have
nothing until you have your characters
doing something that's going to move
your story forward how soon do you
introduce conflict I'm seeing sometimes
conflict is within the first minute
sometimes yes sometimes longer what what
do you think kind of work one exercise
that we do with our clients is we have
them make a list of every possible
conflict that could ever happen to their
character and and then you know try to
come up with 20 things and then we say
okay now come up with ten more and then
come up with ten more and now put them
put it all in your script see how much
conflict you can add to your script and
that's a really common beginner mistake
is that there's just simply not enough
conflict happening in the story and
high-stakes lots of conflict that's what
drives a story so you know it should so
something should happen on page one yeah
or the conflict is only of one nature to
me that's the mistake that so many
Hollywood studio films today that the
conflict is all external conflict you
know or the world is ending the room
yeah you know so we need the superheroes
to come in and and you know stop the bad
guy but know that there's all kinds of
different levels of conflict you know
between human beings there's a
psychological conflict between yourself
between you and and the gods or the fate
you know and and and so the idea of what
the nature of the conflict in your
script if you only have external
conflict coming at your character one
kind of you know like like literally
like somebody just everybody's throwing
stones at them then then this is a
boring movie you need to have all
different kinds of conflict it needs to
be yeah physical emotional spiritual
every every type of yeah so thing story
is not something without conflict you
know stories about conflict and and the
essential conflict in a story by the way
is the conflict between what a character
wants and what they need so you know the
character says I want to be an astronaut
they need to be somebody who can be
a dependent you know interdependent with
other people so the movie ends the story
ends when those two things meet when
when their want becomes their real need
so their want begins to transform and
it's like it's not about being an
astronaut that I should want it's this
thing as soon as the character wants
what they really should want the story's
over but that kind of trying to get
those two things to converge what they
want and what they need that's the
fundamental conflict of any movie and
when a main character gets what they
need that's typically a happy ending
when the main character gets what they
want that's typically a tragedy mm-hmm
let's say I finished my first draft what
am i doing Who am I showing it to what
am I thinking well the very first thing
you should do when you finish a first
draft is go out and celebrate truly
there are so many people that start a
draft and never finish
and you've just by just finishing a
draft you've probably put yourself in
the top 10% of all screenwriters just by
doing that one thing and seeing
something to completion seeing a first
draft come to life that's a really huge
accomplishment especially for a
first-time writer so we really encourage
people to take note of that to celebrate
and then I would say after that take
take a little break from from writing so
that you can be fresh so that you can
come back to it with new eyes now a
first draft is just the very very very
beginning of a very long journey towards
being produced or towards being a
professional screenwriter and so after
you've had a chance to take a break it's
really important to go back to that
draft and look at it through the eyes of
an editor to really look at it
objectively so that you can rewrite it
and we in our book we have a whole
chapter on rewriting and things that you
can do to get your script ready when
it's ready to be seen by eyes other than
your own we generally recommend that
this is where you would send it to your
writers group this is where you would
get professional feedback where you
really need men
ship where you really need somebody who
can guide you through the rewrite
process and once that's happened once
you really have a working draft that you
can send out then you that's when you
start contacting producers that's when
you can start sending it out to
festivals and to contests and things
like that generally speaking we find
that people have more success trying to
work with producers independent
producers and teaming up with people in
that way as opposed to trying to get an
agent or manager right out right out of
the gate it's pretty rare that that
scenario happens with a first-time
writer so you know work with work with
the connections that you have make sure
that your networking make sure that
you're sending it to the people that you
know and if it really is truly ready to
send out to the world you should be
getting back some some pretty positive
responses at that time I would say also
that the the thing about a first project
is that it's not you're not writing it
for it to be made you're writing it to
be your calling card so every writer
needs to have a couple of scripts that
they can show as this is an example of
what I can do I know my craft I know the
business of this art form I can marshal
people's emotions I can take a character
on a journey so because nobody's gonna
buy your first script or yours that
first two scripts you're looking to get
work you're looking for people to say
wow you know what you're doing I have
this little project and weird we need a
writer for it so that that the that
that's why you don't want that first
project to be your weird kind of you
know highly stylized passion thing
because nobody wants to make that you
know they're looking to see can you do a
good basic job of your craft i we need a
writer who can do deliver you strong and
tone and
really deliver strong characters and a
plot that moves so a lot of people have
the wrong sample script they have the
wrong idea of it and then they're just
constantly holding out hope that you
know somebody's gonna buy this script
and they miss the effect that no that's
not what it's for for somebody starting
out you're trying to get work and you
need to show that you know your business
you know your your field so that you
know we stress that with writers all the
time the truth is your first script
probably nobody should ever see your
second script very rarely should anybody
see but when you start okay now you're
in your third project your fourth
project and now you really you know
you're you're getting stuff that should
be seen but but again know what you're
doing with it you know this this is a
sample of your best work it's a sample
of what you can do and so that again you
know two different projects one is more
your particular voice the other one
really shows is as Vicki said you know
you understand John rrah you understand
the the basic structure of storytelling
because that's this mysterious thing to
producers and directors and actors and
they don't know where that comes from
and they need writers who can do that
and so you've got to be able to show I'm
one of those people who can do that so
the the main the main point of creating
this thing is to be your sample and and
what's also extremely important if this
is your first script and you've gotten
it to a place where it is ready to show
people typically the best thing you can
do at that point is to set it aside and
write something else and write your
second script and get that to a place
where you can show people because then
you have two things that you can show
because you know this this business is
funny that way they if they see
something that that they like that is
maybe not for them they're gonna say wow
I like this writer what else do they
have and if you don't have anything else
then that says that you're not ready yet
to be a professional so you really need
to have some things under your belt and
oh by the way your first project
probably shouldn't be a feature your
first project should probably be a short
film or you know an internet you know
web series that are two you know five
two-minute episodes you know or you know
something that kind of
moves you into the feature realm the
future storytelling is the hardest kind
of visual storytelling to do so why
would you start with that you know to
start start you got to walk before you
can run but you'll have more confidence
as you do these little projects and then
you work your way up saying now I'm
ready to write a feature it's amazing
how many people you know start writing
an epic you know scores of the rave
$100,000,000 big-budget thing has their
first project and it's like you're just
not ready to do that again go back to
the metaphor of the the architect you
don't design a skyscraper as your first
thing and your first project needs to be
small in scope so that you can kind of
get better we talk about stories that
have impact versus stories that
entertain what are the two difference
what are the similarities I mean this is
the kind of core of what catharsis is
about you know we called our company
catharsis because this is a word that
Aristotle uses in the poetics to talk
about what story really should be in
people and in society a great story
should lead people to a cathartic
revelation a new understanding it should
open a new insight for them it should
change them in a good way and that as we
brood over stories together as a society
together which we change in a good way
you know that stories help us clarify
our values they help us decide what is
heroic behavior
what is dastardly behavior you know that
stories allow us to process this when
they're good stories that that they lead
to social catharsis unfortunately too
many stories that are being produced
today and I hate to use the word story
you know because they really aren't
doing that at all the core purpose of
story they're they're more conceived as
a product to sell by the the
entertainment industry you know to be
much more like a an amusement park ride
right so we're gonna make them sometimes
I really start there right in there
right yes it's you know but it's like
well let's just take two hours for
people and make them go oh yeah and then
it's over and then they walk out after 2
hours and 14 bucks and or 30 bucks for
popcorn coke and and then the movie
right and and the question is what did I
get from that what is any residual
benefit to me for my life did I get from
that now too many movies the answer is
nothing really nothing that it was
conceived to be like like cotton candy
or a you know and a amusement park ride
and that that's all it was meant to do
it got you there for opening weekend you
plunked down your cash and now you're
done with it and it's done with you we
aspire to encourage riders to have a
much more noble purpose than just
distracting people for two hours kind of
coax people into the theater to plunk
down some money you know the contract
with the audience for us is we're gonna
give you something really worth your
time that that we're gonna give you
something that might help you on your
journey so when you go into the theater
you have your to our experience of
thrills and chills
but it's what you're it's and that's
fine but what it's what you're left with
as you leave the theater that you're
chewing on that is that moment of
catharsis that that we want to have for
the audience to experience and so it's
and that often has to do with the ending
and its final image and and what the
audience is walking away digesting after
having experienced this movie so that
it's not just a two-hour event it's an
event that becomes ingrained into the
rest of their lives and there's
something that they're thinking about
the question for the writer is not what
you're gonna say to the audience in your
movie but what the audience is gonna say
to themselves after this movie you know
I remember a story of one guy that I
heard where he saw Finding Nemo with his
little boy and his wife and he's this
you know big guy he was a marine and you
know not really a philosopher but
they're in the truck driving home after
finding Nemo and and he said to his wife
you know babe
Emily a good dad
you know and I think that to me is a
cathartic story you know he watched this
movie so enjoyable so delightful so
clever and creative but at the end it
provoked him to ask himself am i a good
dad and want to talk about that this is
what we need and it doesn't happen by
accident you know the writer has to have
something to say has something to give
something to share something to propose
that we should brood over in their
concept and and then then that gives
this meat to the project there's just
too many projects that are not solid
meat there's just nothing there there's
nothing really worth sharing and it's
intentionally done that way you know
I've been in unfortunately the Hollywood
development system militates against
something meaty because they're nervous
that it will turn people off right
people we don't we don't want to put
anything in the movie that might make
people think you know that might make
people you know have to you know have to
you know maybe though they won't like it
maybe they won't get it and conversely
they they don't shy away from
controversy but they don't but they do
is shy away from meaning from meaning
yeah and so this is a I think today the
challenge for somebody is a storyteller
today is just shake that off shake off
that I'm here just to create some
sausage you know that's the word they
use in Hollywood for story it's like
we're generating sausage it's like no
we're not we're generating story story
is a beautiful noble important thing
it's critical to a good society and it's
very broken right now so we want
storytellers to kind of really reclaim
their noble purpose the storyteller used
to be in ancient societies right next to
the chief and the priest as the most
important person in the society because
they were going to lead the society to
really look at itself to grow and deepen
we need to get that back nobody right
now would think that Hollywood
storytelling is like you know leading
our society to deepen and grow that's
pathetic and it starts with the writer
and sometimes the writer is the only
person in the room who will champion
that and and and that's okay as so long
as the writer continues to be somebody
who champions that
it won't be completely off the table
when did it change you said today so it
sounds like of a different era different
years 70s 80s maybe years ago it was it
was still around yeah I mean I think
that there were two central changes one
was when Hollywood gone up or broken up
the studio system got broken up in the
post-war period and basically it went
from being movies made by people who
love movies to movies made by
corporations the second thing that
happened was the blockbuster period a
little movie about a shark you know was
shot for eight million dollars or so and
made a you know a billion dollars and
then it was like wow more shark right
you know so the blockbuster period
became this kind of very formulaic model
of a hero driven you know a spectacle
driven project and when we say spectacle
we mean spectacle right you know that
something weird and cool to see and and
that trumped then the inner story you
know the the story of the characters
transformation and so that's what we've
seen you look at these just like scads
and scads and scads of these comic-book
movies or these you know big-budget
action nothing's right and they're
they're just about that they're about
providing two hours of spectacle and
it's about let's you know we'll make
this movie for 100 million and it'll
make 500 million and and that's that's
all it's about it's a product to be sold
it's about coaxing the audience into
opening weekend and and and there's no
concern for what well what is this story
really saying so the writer has to have
enough confidence in themselves and
their vocation to say no you know I'm
not just making sausage I want to make
something that will leave my world and
the people in my audience in a better
place and so we're fine producers who
also resonate with that find you know
new we want to you know really
Renaissance in this in this storytelling
industry it's gonna start with the
writers and it can happen on the big
studio level and you'll see that the
story there are some that make their way
through there that have both and and
ultimately they end up doing much better
at the box office anyway just thinking
back to ET I mean I
that's a blockbuster from many years ago
there were the toys there were all the
things that went with it but there was
still that that emotion every part and
beautiful story about a coming-of-age
movie
I mean coming-of-age movies there's
almost a dead genre right now what does
that say you know we we've lost even the
faith to say that you would go on a
growth journey as a young person you
know we don't want to say that anymore
there's almost no coming-of-age movies I
think that's what makes boyhood so fresh
it's like wow we haven't seen a
coming-of-age story for so long so I
think that that the storytelling is
broken we just have to acknowledge it
it's broken and and we need to look back
to the classical era
I think the classical nature of story we
have to look back to move forward and
that we have to read say no story has a
nature humanity has it has a nature and
and they have to work together we're
gonna reclaim the purpose of story in
our society and really start to bring
people back to the the the movies again
and so that they walk out and say you
know that was cool like that one I want
to talk to people about and that's what
makes a classic that's what makes it
last for 50 hundred years